Maxime ouvr from jardiluxe what do you
mean la décision pasquelle vous parlez
pas boulot aujourd'hui non en plus il y
a romain il est trop content de te crois
max yes
ROM est trop content il est toujours
contenton rain un piano il tomberait sur
la gueule il dirait j'adore la musique
il est là Maxim comment ça va le
meilleur d'entre nous Hubert il faut
vraiment que je vous parle du contrat
max c'est un déjeuner de famille on est
dimanche on parle pas business ah merde
mais merde ma veste la mère à la
putainabula fils de là M la
j'en peux plus de tes humeurs c'est
justement le thème du stage que je vais
faire comprendre les énergies qui nous
gouvernent pour mieux les dominer c'est
super prends avec toi ah mais super
idée tu vois c'est joli ouais c'est joli
on va à poudelarde je te préviens je
tiendrai pas 4 jours désolé on t'a dit 4
jours c'est 14 allez
ciao je vais aller fouiller dans vos
trips pour faire bouger vos énergies s
instable en fait non mais Volverine
c'est Xmen en fait fa qu' me touche le
clit toi tu es dans la vérité tu veux
plus rien me cacher faut que j'aille
faire caca faut trier quand même he tu
es pas obligé de tout me
dire saon du pâté un truc à bouffer là
c'est un stage pour les tortues en fait
maman je t'ai dit que je n'étais pas
joignable cette semaine ton père est en
train de faire visiter le magasin un
agent immobilier c'est pas assez grand
ici pour me coller comme des tics le
connard du GR quoi croire tu entendu par
contre mettez votre masque non mais ça
va aller monsieur mais tomonas les PR ou
je t'éteins la lumière tu veux pas me
toucher le clitau pardon ils en D j'ai
vu reportage sur 90 minutes d'enquête
exclusif si vous sentez en danger vous
faites le
code je vais encastrer tout le
monde alors tu aimes bien la nourriture
végane ouais tu vois j'ai décidé de
vivre comme une chèvre puis après je
vais aller me faire tirer le lait pour
faire des yaours
bio